what's up everyone welcome we have moved
the simulation recording studio we are
still in the beautiful Silicon Valley
California but rather than being right
in the heat of downtown San Francisco we
are now in the beautiful San Mateo over
near 280 by the Crystal Springs
reservoir I just walked around it today
it's gorgeous
more calm and spiritual out here also we
are now without Ron Vargas who was the
producer and director of the show for
those first 500 or so episodes and we
are now working together with this man
right here whose name is Ori
Shapira hi Ori hey I like it when you
say it with your voice there wory
Shapira
for those that have watched the episodes
with Ori we did the episode with him
when he was explaining what holding
space was and then we did in another
episode with him where he held space for
me on the show and we had a really nice
transformation and consciousness that
occurred a nice evolution for me
occurred there and Ori is not only
coming on board to do things like
produce the show and switch between
cameras and whatnot and add really good
ideas and also add his take from behind
the set as we talked on the show but
also
we are now holding space with all of the
guests that come on the show it's now an
included part of the show experience yes
it's beautiful because even while we do
the co-creating of the outline with the
guests we're mentioning to them as we're
saying this is the intro this is what we
have in your bio this is what we're
gonna talk about do you have any
thoughts about this and we tell them at
the very end afterward after we ask you
a couple last questions that we're gonna
hold space with you we're just gonna be
together and that we're gonna evolve
consciousness together that way and it's
great because it's like a massive
pendulum swing from the interview
energetically to just being afterward
and Ori joins us and leads the holding
space session afterward and we've now
been experienced experimenting with that
for a dozen or more shows and it's been
a lot of fun we've had people that have
stuck around and just sat with us and
had really deep emotional transformation
spiritual transformations it's been
quite nice and orey's been teaching me a
lot as well about just
a myriad of critical things that I need
to learn about human connection and
about silence and about how deep we can
get into the psyche and about the
importance of what holding space and
having a really strong container can
actually do and probably one of the
coolest things was was that in this
grand massive experience of being alive
together on this rock orbiting start
this creation experiment that we're all
a part of that we're all trying to make
some sort of meaningful impact in we
typically think that the faster that I
talk and the more that I say I can
compress and that the other person can
learn much more that way but we're so
socialized to just talk our asses off
all the time that we forget that
actually really powerful transformations
can sometimes occur even more powerful
transformations can occur from not
socializing and instead from just
slowing down and just being together and
by doing that you can unlock really cool
things and ori and i will be showcasing
that more and more with the evolution of
the show over time ori let's hear from
you about this transition well
I just feel right now like
a kid in a candy store with new toys
because this studio environment and
[Music]
creating things that may garner a lot of
eyeballs I'm still coming into that and
it's exhilarating
and a little scary but I've never felt
more aligned
I also feel like
a kid with new toys it's great that Ron
was able to help teach a lot of the
technical knowledge that we need to be
able to operate the TriCaster and
robotic cameras just to get a multi
camera shoot flowing and I also feel
like I have a bunch of new toys with
what he's been teaching me and so it'll
be cool when it's more evident for
people to identify that alan is now
approaching things a little bit
differently I think it was even on a
recent show that we did that someone had
mentioned something that was a little
bit deeper about emotion or spirit and I
was very welcoming for them to take a
pause and to unpack that more about
their life
and I also feel like your
your drive to be aligned right now with
this endeavor and with the way that we
could leverage the equipment and what's
been formulating in our essences to to
really showcase profound transformations
in consciousness it's excellent it's
excellent and just pumped to be able to
leverage the equipment for that well
there must be
there's even a hole there's even a whole
thing called him dead air that radio
used to talk about all the time and
video talks about it now this idea of
dead air like it's basically a sin to
have long periods of time without saying
anything and like that paradigm is so
being changed right now by Ori and by so
many others that are just like screw
that I'm just gonna just be I'm gonna be
with people and just be like we can you
know like worry taking time to see what
came up for him to say next we actually
had a decent amount of that on the on
our show with holding space to where
that was happening maybe an interesting
idea to actually hold space right now
I'd love to let's do it okay all right
cool
yeah let's see if I just turn here if I
still if I look at you like this how do
I look on their turn a little bit more
towards the camera that's better okay
yeah needs to your face more that way
okay
I can also use the mixed effect shot
where we showcase all of the cameras at
the same time we can do that at another
time or I could go do that right now why
don't we give this a shot let's see
let's give this a shot so it's good all
right
[Music]
hey Alan yeah
what do you think you're doing
sharing your beloved show with this man
and feels like Dada's channeling through
and the wind has moved in this direction
and it feels more aligned with the
divine calling of the North Star that is
within this blueprint within this Spirit
meeting with this body for this artistic
expression that our nodes collide for
this portion
it's like a chapter in the book
but people don't know about me and they
don't know about the stuff I do
they know about you and that's proven
the most important thing is that what
content ends up being created from our
inter place as well as the inter place
of when guests come on the show for
interviews as well as holding space as
long as the content there that is being
created is exciting and inspirational
educational then the right work is being
done and that's what matters
this updated team at simulation what are
we a recipe for
for a full-fledged spiritual evolution
and for not only the the interviewees
that come in for them to have more deep
spiritual evolution but also for the
guests to be able to feel like they come
even more so from their hearts that they
express themselves even better than
before and then for the audience to for
them to feel like whoa there's an even
more spiritual transformation that's
happening even better content is being
made now and there's another component
which is this holding space component
that's happening on camera as well it'll
depend on if the guests will choose to
bring that part on camera or not and
we're excited for the ones that do so we
can share that
is a viral viewership in the cards
of course
the tree of possibilities all exists
all excess
with harder and smarter work
one can achieve those Northstar goals
more effectively and a definition of
what a viral viewership is is also very
important because I prefer to have a
couple people that that have their
consciousness transformed that go off
and get inspired and go and talk to more
people about the subject or go and
transform even more people's
consciousness or go and build things
related the fields that were discussed
I'd rather have that then have so many
more people that are just watching and
then don't get transformed and don't do
anything afterward so it's more actually
about the transmissive property of the
awakening than it is about just a count
of people
you talk so much about spirituality in
words like that in your show is full of
powerful minds in tech business
entrepreneurship and more so
how dare you
do that
yeah as
[Music]
many of the audience me know as well as
as much as I know from about a year and
a half ago or so approaching now two
years ago that the intent of asking very
thought-provoking questions to different
leaders in their fields it was about
that transmissive property of awakening
to other people oh my gosh what are we
going to do about wealth inequality what
are we going to do about the
democratization of exponential
technologies how are we going to handle
these things
and bringing on the different leading
scientists entrepreneurs artists
spiritual leaders people in so many
different pressing fields and blockchain
and crypto and AI robotics biotech neuro
tech geopolitics geo-economics emotional
intelligence all these different fields
it was so interesting bringing on the
different people in talking them about
what they're building why it's important
and asking them poking questions about
ethics and slowly but surely it started
going more and more in the direction of
like you know what is the meaning of
life what is the purpose of the human
experiment who or what created this what
is source what is spirituality
how do people feel when they tap in to
thinking and feeling like that and how
does it affect their what they're
building in those other fields so that
has been such a profound realization
recently that if you poke an endeavor
into the philosophical the moral the
spiritual the religious the creationary
the evolutionary aspects of what this
human experiment is why we're here what
this person's purpose is how they
connect to a deeper more transcendent
state those types of questions if you do
that more with the guests then it
actually drives their science and their
business and their art and all the other
endeavoring that they're doing with
their families their communities with
employees all that type of stuff much
better those two things are not separate
things they go hand-in-hand science and
spirituality business and spirituality
they go hand in hand art and
spirituality so actually science
business and art without spirituality is
a disaster
and you see it everywhere you look in
our civilization super disconnected
people that are building the future and
that's why there's a lack of
philosophers a lack of moral scientists
a lack of ethicists that are supposed to
be working with all the people that are
building AI and that are working in the
field of biotech or neuro
Tec there seems to be a lot of
spirituality around blockchain and
decentralization which is great
a lot of spirituality around
psychedelics and meditation and even
some with neuro tech but it still seems
as though there's people that want to
just jam neuroprosthetics into your
brain
without even taking the time to reflect
on their own connection to God their own
connection to source - what's
transcendent of humans and so then
that's the goal
if we can bring more and more of these
brilliant minds in Silicon Valley in
Shenzhen London tel-aviv all these
different cities around the world if we
can bring warm the powerful minds that
are so deeply building the future into a
more spiritually communing state as they
build then we have a much higher
likelihood of positively affecting the
trajectory of our world and then people
at home can also or where they're tuning
from can also tap more deeply into their
spiritual essences as they're also
building the future
how can these potentially potentially
edgy ideas really touch people
how can people be moved toward the way
you're perceiving
well
first is that it's not just about how
I'm perceiving but also about how so
many of the other people like you like
mama knew each one like so many of these
banty neo Sadhguru so many of these
other leaders in spirituality around the
world how they're perceiving we just had
Sandy heart joyous heart on our show the
way that they're perceiving why are
people perceiving in a way that it
pieces together the most question
marquee areas of what is our purpose
here and
when
when we start endeavoring ourselves into
those question marquee puzzle pieces of
what we're doing here what is our
purpose here that's what brings us the
most meaning and fulfillment
so these edgy ideas are actually the
most important ideas if you are the
person that continuously asks themselves
what is my role here you will go so much
further in life than those that never
ask themselves that question in same
thing if you do it not only to yourself
but then you go and do it to it everyone
else if you are that person that is
constantly talking to people about what
is their role in this human experiment
then they will constantly be thinking
also themselves about what is my role
the more people that are constantly
thinking that the more awakened people
are what did I come here to do what is
my role here okay I endeavor a little
bit more in this direction hmm that was
pretty interesting
I like that maybe I should do a little
bit more of that in my life I endeavor
it in here mm-hmm didn't really feel it
so much okay maybe a little bit of less
of that consciously living life living
life and feeling that I'm connecting
more deeply with my purpose in the
directions that I go
Auri how do you feel about the
integration of spirituality more deeply
into the show and what your role is with
that and also what it can bring to
others
both the guests and viewers
I think that it my role is to
be something spiritual
and
[Music]
even I don't know what that will look
like
but
what else is more worthwhile it's kind
of how I feel like
well I'll also share that emotionally
Allen
in this moment
I'm feeling
Allen
yes
um
I'm feeling something that isn't cool
tell us more
it's
it feels exactly like that it just feels
like right now I'm being the opposite of
cool like that's just the emotional
experience that our belief that is
present with my system what does the
opposite of being cool mean uncool
not just that
[Music]
like not a good fit
not a good fit for what
like
this show and whoever I'm imagining is
watching it
I feel that way
because
I don't feel entertaining or at speed
like my pace feels unusually slow and
[Music]
that's part of the change
the mainstream culture all narrative of
everything needs to be densely packed
everything needs to be at light speed as
fast as possible that is very quickly
breaking apart
that
that we spend a dozen years of our lives
learning language but we want to be
spiritually enlightened in a one-minute
video that's a joke that
we want to compete so hard at being the
best economy in the world that we
pillage and plunder and enslave and put
all our ethics to the side to do so
that's a joke
we know that our connection to nature
and our connection to each other at
deeper levels and at slower paces is a
massive key in unlocking the next
evolutions of consciousness and that
what seems to be uncool is actually cool
I don't want to not shine
I don't want to be boring
every moment of our life is shining and
one of the big keys of life is to
realize that every moment of life is
shining even me from a couple years ago
first learning how to dive deeper into
interviewing was it's funny to look back
at now but that is still shining it's
it's gross all I can think about is
the eyeballs on the other side of the
camera
beautiful
to care that you have four that is
actually exactly what's needed right now
when people sit down together on camera
mostly people are thinking about how can
I become more popular how can I earn
more money how can I become more famous
that is very quickly being sniffed out
by people and they're saying mm-hmm
that's not my ethic but when people that
go on camera are obsessed with what
other people are seeing and they want to
care for those people that are watching
care for every moment in time that those
people are investing into watching what
is being shown to them and discussed
that's that is beautiful to care that
deeply and to make sure that what is
being communicated is enriching
hmm
what if people don't feel called to slow
down to this speed when they see us
out of the distribution of people
out of the totality there are people
that are disengaged at this speed and
that is fine there are people that even
in that group that are like why are they
doing that and they become slightly more
engaged then there are the people that
are already slightly engaged that are
like why am I seeing stuff like this
more often and then there are the people
that are already quite engaged and stuff
like this
that distribution is very important to
keep in mind
and our responsibility is to help make
sure that for those that are even a tiny
been engaged all the way up to quite
engaged are gaining further enrichment
and inspiration
the TriCaster out
the dialogue is taking place in because
the TriCaster is quite loud
Cary's each side eyes would be nice for
there to be just yeah
studio shows that exists now that you
try counselors have their try casters in
life are a room or two even outside of
the rooms are doing the studio show in
that way that things not making any
noise in the studio space
with your help
[Music]
we got you know packs of interesting
weights base to your questions
I feel rap
yeah I feel better I feel like
energetically you kind of held space for
me which which was nice
we continued that for each other quite a
bit
with her family's - it has been very
interesting
yeah actually for those that don't do
this yet like please take your your
newly found
friends trusted
spiritual sisters and brothers to your
family take them there or have family
come to you with them because it's
transformative what happens with your
relationship with your family members
when someone else that is trusted that
is already quite consciously evolve and
spiritually evolved can partake in the
dialogue in a three instead of just a
two person dynamic it's super life
changing
yeah
yeah we're stuck in like like a 25-year
relationship with our mom or our dad or
whatever person and like you're
literally stuck and because you're you
know each other's perspectives quite
well on a lot of things and you're
constantly are we're trying to you know
kind of like nudge each other and all
this other type of stuff when you add in
that that third fresh perspective that's
trusted and friendly and wants to help
consciously evolve the - it's it's
critical so it's a Magus mission
critical to do stuff like that
[Applause]
it's also interesting that whenever we
like hold space we don't we never know
what is gonna happen so we've been
holding space with just Ori and I
sometimes just three people with one
other person and even recently we held
space with seven people that was fire ah
it was all like close people in my life
too and we
just had a gorgeous evolution together
like literally seven people
and just be
if you think about it for a perspective
of information theory in conscious
evolution the idea would be how can you
mathematically represent conscious
evolution in the shortest amount of time
in the answer lies in holding space it
does not lie in I'm gonna talk to you
99.9% of our existence when we engage
with another person is just talking and
talking and talking and usually we're
just waiting for other people to finish
what they're saying is that we can say
what we want to say and how much
conscious or spiritual evolution is
actually occurring then versus the point
one percent of the time and soon to be
way more than that once things like this
spread that when you're just there being
with each other and you're tapping
deeper into yourself that copy deeper
into the other and the relationship
between the two or up to the seven or
more that are there and Ori will also be
explaining what it's like holding space
for large events of hundred-plus people
what does it feel like to be in a
stadium that's filled with 50,000 people
when you're just there and you're just
feeling what 50,000 people are feeling
again you're not just watching the event
or it sounds like the next evolution in
the human race you know I'm saying bro
hundred percent
yeah
just because like bigger bow of a loan
it is to take on it's huge and it's
gorgeous
that hasn't seen the potential feeling
the potential
I'm super-pumped I'm so pumped that
all ready for what - what
bori is what always helped me add to
this tool belt also 4th
what worries already helped with the
guests that we've had on the show
afterward how we're going to be starting
to also be recording those and showing
those transformations and consciousness
after the shows together and I'm pumped
to get to that vision where the next
evolution of humans is humans that are
more sensitive humans that are more
deeply connected to source
I'm so jazzed for that
Yeah right
shall we yeah all right let's - thanks
everyone for tuning in we appreciate it
they're fun updating you with what's
going on
it's so nice to be for those that really
want to be sensitive for a moment think
about the metropolis that the majority
of you live in there are thousands if
not tens of thousands of other humans
that are all in extremely close
proximity to you and there are also
hundreds if not thousands of cars that
are always constantly in proximity
driving by you if there's constantly
electromagnetic fields that are all
around you all the time
the amount of just machines of all
different sorts that are there are just
constantly bombarding your energetic
field now contrast that with how you
feel when you're right next to the ocean
or how you feel when you're in the
middle of the woods
contrast those two things
because one feels like we are literally
being scrambled
that's just worker bees and the other
one feels like we're connect
something that is divine that transcends
us so
now the show being away from this
downtown metropolis and more so in
nature in a more conducive location to
spiritual evolution and transformation
is not only helping me as a host or as a
producer and all the guests that come on
the show it's also gonna make it a
better experience for you as viewers
that get to see that
feel it yeah it's a huge huge thank you
to everyone that's continuously been
supporting us and continue to support
the artists entrepreneurs the spiritual
leaders organizations around the world
do you believe
continue supporting them and helping
them grow and keep supporting us our
links are in the bio below try and slow
down and hold more space with your
family your friends co-workers people
online do it do more often that's an
interesting one else to see what we
precipitance between holding space in
person and trying to hold space / video
or yeah well that can be done too and
also if you're really curious reach out
to me you know Alan is gonna be
traveling for a few weeks here in August
and so I'll have more time to do that
with others yeah is email cool yeah
or you can go to WWE holding space calm
this contact there yeah or the holding
space calm contact or e and also our
email a simulation series at gmail.com
and Ori has access to that email
so he can field enquiries from there as
well and you know that getting touches
in the Bible all the videos GS can be
getting in touch with any of the other
episodes and really do give that a go
give holding space ago lessen your
thoughts in the
yeah let us enter thoughts in the
comments below would love to hear from
you on all the things you've talked
about and ask yourself that question
more often what is my purpose here what
is my purpose here and ask other people
what is your purpose here
what is your North Star get asking that
more often and build that future
everyone manifest your dreams in the
world I love it very much
you
yes yes yes